[Applaus]
ich weiß ja nicht wann ich das letzte
mal ein pappbecher benutzer das ist ja
dass wir nicht mal ein verbrechen an der
umwelt nehmen
der kaffee schmeckt doch einfach scheiße
ja stimmt was mir einfällt hafermehl
laktose nicht in diesem körper da macht
ihn ruhig in den mehrweg bambus becher
ist okay aber das ist kein vergleich zu
dem café wurde
umweltbewusst und benutzt ein becher ich
glaube es ist zeit für konsum
kapitel 1 pappbecher sinnvoller sie ich
rette die welt mit dem mehrwegbecher in
deutschland werden jedes jahr fast drei
milliarden einwegbecher verkauft das
sind 320.000 pro stunde das ist doch
totaler wahnsinn deshalb auch mehr
welcher bambus becher gut kritik gut
gemacht was denn das problem ist nicht
der becher sondern
der kaffee was war das cappuccino das
solltest du das gemacht gottverdammte
hits wie die herstellung von nur ein
kilo reis kaffee braucht man beim anbau
und beim waschen der bohnen 21.000 liter
wasser und das in ländern die ähnlich
viel wasser haben 140 liter vereinen
welcher kann das ist kein normaler
kaffee
das ist ein stück weit weniger milch und
der chart ich weiß du hast nicht nur
einen co2 du hast auch einen wasser
fußabdruck
zum vergleich ein kilo baumwolle
verbraucht 11.000 liter wasser ein ein
200 liter
ein liter bier 300 liter wasser das ja
quasi nichts
und deswegen trinke ich morgens nur noch
bier der umwelt zuliebe prost
[Musik]
gut aber echt supi denn mehrwegbecher
wilson schlusskapitel zwei plastiktüten
[Musik]
wir alles papier ganz ehrlich meine mir
heute noch irgendwas den kauf der ist
also ich meine kann auch gleich den
gerichten natürlich den plastiktüten
scheiße aber ein weg papiertüten sind
auch nicht gefreut
damit die dinger mit so schweren sachen
die flaschenmilch himalaya salz und hier
sahen nicht reißen braucht man sehr
lange und sehr festen stoff war sein das
braucht wieder viel wasser energie und
chemikalien
ja gut aber ich meine der einweg
papiertüte ist auch nicht die beste aber
jetzt sind wir nur noch unverpackt der
verbrauch im klassischen plastiktüten
hat sich in den letzten zwei jahren zwar
halbiert
aber von diesen händchen beute benutzten
wir immer noch pro jahr über drei jahren
stück jetzt mal ganz ehrlich macht das
jetzt für eine sache ist die kurze und
die gute alte classic tötet immer noch
richtig gut und zwar als
kapitel 3
die generation online rettet die welt
café klasse das alles pillepalle gegen
die wahren probleme in der welt ihr
guckt petition gegen kinderarbeit in
afrikanischen sweatshops ein klick schon
unterschrieben und wieder mal ein gutes
werk getan aber zum online gehen
brauchen wir strom und jede menge
komplizierte technik habe ich mir ganz
kurz ihr smartphone ein wenn wir ein
beliebiges smartphone ganz ganz
vorsichtig öffnen
darin finden wir lithium kobalt und gold
allein 30 verschiedene metalle
[Musik]
hallo
urlaub machen wo die rohstoffe für ihr
handy her kommen warum nicht mal denn
sie schauen sie zu wie kobalt touristen
lernten aus der erde gekratzt werden und
wo noch nicht bald etwas wunderbares
rechten gehört hat oder vorjahr liegen
sie doch mal nach chile wo durch den
abbau von lithium der spiegel sie so
dass hin bauer die walter verloren also
nicht jedes jahr das neueste handy
modell kaufen das bringt auf jeden fall
mehr als petition zu unterschreiben was
sorry ich schaue gerade die neue staffel
von family guy außerdem früher bin ich
zum shoppen mit dem auto in die stadt
gefahren
heute macht das alles online das spart
energie und der strom fürs laptop ist
100% winter ja nun ein
die hälfte aller menschen 3,7 milliarden
sind mittlerweile online wäre das
internet ein land es hätte den sechs
größten energieverbraucher der welt
der bedarf von cloud speichern
rechenzentren server netzwerk technik
usw
die geschätzte 12 milliarden
kilowattstunden
klimafreundlicher wäre es weniger online
zu sein hier weniger alle hier also gar
nicht wenn ja auch weniger online sein
wollen bleibt es doch unten in die
kommentare
na die wahrheit tut wer wird ihr euch
schlecht gut so
wisst ihr wie ihr euch noch viel
schlechter fühlt indem er die nächste
folge verpasst oder abonniert einfach
diesen kanal dann passiert das nicht
nein